you know there's a lot of things we
could talk about uh but where I wanted
to start is where you started with this
film and
what story you had in your mind that you
were going to tell when you first went
over there and started
you know recording what you saw uh I
assume you keep an open mind anytime you
enter a project about where it goes but
but you must go in with some sense of
direction some arrow pointing you
somewhere what what kind of film did you
think you were going to make when you
went
I I say this with pretty much every film
I make and it still holds true with
every film I make when I was 21 years
old
I heard Al maisel speak and he said if
you end up with a story you started with
and you weren't listening along the way
which I think is good advice for for
Life yeah it's good advice for
filmmaking you know be open the story
changing don't be dogmatic and that's
certainly something that that was true
with this film
um it took about two or three years to
get access
to actually embed with the Green Berets
um when we first started it wasn't even
clear that it would be about Afghanistan
or that would be about the end of the
war
by the time we actually got permission
covid delays
it actually looked like oh maybe we
could like look at this what you know
this this film could be a prism to look
at the end of the longest war in U.S
history and you didn't know it was going
to end when you started no making your
inroads and then I mean
it seemed like it might end but it
wasn't a faded complete necessarily
and two months into filming you know
Biden pulled out our troops
and I I just was sort of left like
I don't think we have a film here you
know this is probably the First Act of a
film and it's it's
not a complete film and so and obviously
the story wasn't over at that point and
so we reached back out to General Sadat
um the Afghan General that we followed
through the film
and and asked him you know would you be
open to us coming back and spending time
with you and he said he said yes and
completely pivoted
um the lens of the story to focus on
seeing this final chapter through his
eyes
tell us about
securing that access because it's
extraordinary what you got to see and I
wondered just as a as a journalist how
you established the trust that was
necessary to to have those people the
Green Berets and then General Sadat and
all of the people working with him I
mean they're putting their lives on the
line but they're also inviting you in to
capture
what I presume are some of the most
difficult moments of their lives
definitely I mean I think
in you know access intimacy is the
Bedrock of what I do
um and that trust is not just given no
at the beginning of a film it's
something that's
that's earned
it's a sort of vow that you renew
sometimes weekly sometimes hourly
sometimes every five minutes you know
this was a the stakes could not have
been higher here
and you know we owe so much to him and
his men for opening up their lives to us
and the the most difficult moment in in
their lives
and uh
yeah I mean certainly
we were constantly having doors shutting
our face
um and trying to open those doors
um because it was you know it was really
difficult and it was by far the hardest
time I've ever made
physically emotionally logistically
um it's not an easy environment to
operate in what was the process of just
embedding with the green braids you said
it took a couple of years from your
first introduction like what do you have
to do in order to get that placement
um you know I think they obviously
looked at my body at work
um I my producing partner Caitlin
McNally
um had worked with them previously and
so she you know she had a long rapport
with them
um but it had to go you know all the way
up to the Pentagon I mean it's it's it
it took a very very long time to gain
their trust viewing you were they asking
you like would it obviously you
mentioned your body of work you're an
established person they can they realize
you're not just some
person wants an adventurer who wants to
come over and with a camera but but what
kind of questions do they ask you or
what what do you have to do in order to
present yourself as somebody you could
be trusted in warza
um
you know all the sort of typical uh you
know what your what's your angle what do
you what do you hope to get out of this
um what's your Footprints
um you know how big a crew I mean all
the questions that sort of affect would
affect their lives on a daily basis
um and in this this the length of this
embed had never happened before in the
Special Forces Community you know it's a
very insular
community that doesn't like to show what
they do
um and and the green braids in
particular are sort of describe
themselves as like quiet professionals
they don't like to talk about what they
do they don't like to show what they do
and so it was definitely a very unique
prism that we were able to see
so once you get over there what's the
relationship like with the people you're
you're you're capturing that you're
recording the Green Berets like you say
they're a stoic Bunch uh do you find
yourself engaging in their camaraderie
do you try to be a ghost
a fly on the wall
what's your approach to to being there
and making sure that everybody trusts
you
I don't love the term fly on the wall
but that sort of implies a
no offense to flies but
um uh you know a lack of Engagement
um
uh sort of an impartial view I don't I
don't know like like what I like to say
is I like to become part of the fabric
of the daily lives and my subjects
um again through gaining their trust
through building that trust
and it doesn't happen overnight it takes
weeks months sometimes years depending
on what the film is
um to make them comfortable
um and in this case
you know we're filming with General
Sadat like
from the moment he woke up in the
morning Tony went to bed at night and
everything in between and so it was
um
you know in the beginning obviously that
was as an onerous thing for him and his
guys but then I think you know after a
couple days a couple weeks again I just
became part of the okay Matt sits in the
left seat in the car General sadata is
on the right back seat driver you know
it's like we had her sort of arranged
um
where the Rhythm that we got did the
Green Berets and general Sadat see
independently of uh of your personality
and your footprint your interaction with
them did they see a value in having
their story told
was there was that an aspect of allowing
you to capture all this that they wanted
this to be captured
of course yeah I mean that's that's the
sort of
I think if you ask any documentary
subject
throughout the history of documentaries
most people question why does anyone
take part in a documentary and I think
if the if there's one common denominator
it's that you know they people want to
be understood people want to be heard
and
um
you know this is obviously a historic
moment and and I think everyone felt
like it was a very important moment to
capture and in some sense the film is a
yeah as a historical document of this
final chapter of the longest war in U.S
history
it's so clear that empathy is one of
I mean it's it's a it's a key filmmaking
tool for anyone but uh you know watching
this film I I was so overcome so many
times
and I wondered if you could talk to me
about empathy as a as a as a tool of a
Storyteller uh I imagine you feel these
things very intensely I can't imagine
standing there uh that that uh looked
like a canal of some sort that they were
standing in that people were trying to
to uh uh get airlifted out it was full
of water I don't know what that exactly
was
um
but I I imagine it's it's hard to look
at this look in their faces and and know
that some of these people are trying to
get out because they know they'll be
killed uh if and when the government
Falls
um but you you also have to control that
right in in order to tell your story to
keep going you can't let your emotions
overcome you right so how do you manage
that
I mean I think
just sort of step back up into the
clouds for a second I think that's
that's one of the things that I try to
do in making these films is taking large
amorphous subjects
the drug war in Mexico Isis in Syria
covid things that are sort of plastered
across headlines
were inundated with these things but we
never really often engage with them
and so I feel like it's my job
my responsibility
to to try to humanize them to try to you
know put a human face them and try to
make you feel whatever like what it
would be like to be in that helicopter
or in that trench
um and maybe just maybe in doing so Make
You Care
just a little bit more
and that scene that you referenced at
the end of the film
with thousands of Afghan civilians
desperately trying to flee
was unlike anything I'd ever experienced
in my career I filmed a lot of really
sad things in my life
um
I've certainly cried in the edit room
at film festivals you know many times in
the filmmaking process
I've never cried while shooting
and I constantly found myself
both wiping my face and and like
defogging the eyepiece of the of the
camera
it just was it was so surreal to see
these thousands of people sitting in a
four foot sewage ditch for four foot
deep sewage ditch
[Music]
um
as 18 year old Marines were making these
impossible Sophie's Choice decisions on
who to let in
who not to let in
as the Taliban was sitting 100 yards
away at gunpoint
watching us
as Isis
was circling around with suicide vests
waiting to attack which happened 12
hours later in that very spot that we
were filming in
and
all I could think about was what have we
done
thank you for making the film thank you
very much Matthew Heineman everyone
thank you for being here thanks for
sticking around thank you thanks for
joining us
[Music]